britney es libre al fin una vez que la
jueza brenda penny puso fin a la tutela
que ha controlado la vida personal y el
patrimonio de 60 millones de dólares de
la cantante pop estadounidense durante
casi 14 años el júbilo estalló en las
afueras del tribunal superior de los
ángeles con cientos de fans que
celebraron la noticia
britney quien compareció a la audiencia
virtualmente no tardó en reaccionar a la
decisión en sus redes sociales dios mío
quiero tanto a mis fans que es una
locura voy a llorar el resto del día el
mejor día de mi vida alabado sea el
señor me pueden dar un amén la tutela
fue establecida por el padre de la
cantante jamie spears desde que ella
sufrió un colapso público y se sometió a
tratamientos por problemas de salud
mental no revelados en 2008 y fue tan
solo hasta septiembre de este año que la
jueza suspendió al padre del artista
como curador legal
hoy la jueza penny después de la
audiencia
decidió dar la razón abril de spears
y a partir de hoy con efecto inmediato
la tutela se ha terminado en cuanto a la
persona y el patrimonio
rosell de éste aunque parecía que la
tutela podía continuar durante años el
emotivo discurso de spears del 23 de
junio de este año en el que describió
las restricciones impuestas en su vida
como abusivas fue clave para que no
hubiera solicitud de prórroga en la
tutela el padre de la cantante todavía
podría ser investigado por la gestión
monetaria de la artista y por
presuntamente haber implantado un
dispositivo de escucha en su dormitorio